[Music]
there are lots of internationally
successful equestrians Thomas Feinberg
for instance won silver at European
Championships in Prague but not many of
them started their own companies at the
age of 19 the way he did
hello my name is Thomas Bach hello I'm
Thomas vine bag I'm 27 years old
this is gigolo John I'm here on my land
and and where I coach riders and work
with horses I'm a show jumper myself and
today I'd like to show you a few places
in often you might not know about
Weinberg grew up with equestrian sports
his parents were also successful show
jumpers and coaches and he followed in
their footsteps
he buys young horses trains them
presents them at competitions and sells
them it's unique sport because you work
individually with each animal and
they're all different it's an
interesting job something new every day
working with horses means everything to
me
Feinberg's first recommendation is
auctions equestrian Stadium it seats
some 40,000 spectators and it's one of
the largest horse riding venues in the
world each year it hosts the CHEO or
conker at peak international official
featuring Four Nations Cup events
that's his permission for me this is the
most important and most beautiful place
in the world it's the world stage of
equestrian sport once a year the
showjumping elite meet here to compete
the audience in oven is amazing absolute
beer is like nowhere else
everyone should experience this at least
once I'm Molly lip Tommy
[Applause]
the CHEO is one of the world's oldest
and most renowned tournaments more than
500 horses 300 riders and 350 thousand
spectators take part it's a great show
and great sport and there's plenty of
glitz and glamour
outside the stadium as well so here
isn't goodbye walk we're at a walk of
fame sort of like Hollywood but with
horses these are original shoes worn by
world-famous horses that have won the
Grand Prix oven in our sport the horses
of the stars not the humans dimension
for his second tip we plunge into
auctions history we enter the city
centre through the front gate he has
employed a coup negatory Kings used to
go through this gate to their
coronations in the Market Square this
was the entrance to Nathan's outer city
walls nowadays it's the entrance to
paunch Strasse where you can find lots
of pubs and restaurants and other
interesting places I'm not offended
whether at noon or at night students or
business people everyone meets unfelt
Raza the university is around the corner
prices in the bars and restaurants are
moderate and the people of Aachen are
very cosmopolitan the shop Jonathan is
the charm of Aachen is simply that
because the border is nearby there are
lots of international visitors no
ordinary German city can match Athens
Flair
now border is the crucial word the third
recommendation is outside the city
limits you can take a long walk or drive
there he is in Valhalla we're in the
Netherlands here were Belgium and now
I'm in Germany yes since in Deutschland
the try point in the tri border area is
a popular day trip destination and
always good for a snapshot here the
borders of the Netherlands Belgium and
Germany meet and you can experience the
European Union's open borders firsthand
[Music]
any one of the restaurants in the Tri
border area is the perfect place to
drink to that
yes my hats we've come to the end of our
trip for today I'm sitting in the
Netherlands with my Belgian beer and
there's a beautiful view of auckland
from here
[Music]
you